there was a little bit of I guess a Kur
fuffle when you pulled in no I don't
know what tell you what I had to deal
with just tell me if I all I want to do
is fire people I know and I want to
watch you fire people so this is last
time I came this was not here I was at a
you a place this our facility that we've
had for about two years now yeah and you
came I think you were the first person
that came uh in during the height of Co
the height of Co you came in person
coughing on everyone uhhuh well I didn't
think Co was real so I was like here I
am
I came in didn't care uh that was a
different place because this place
wasn't done yet but this this is my uh
my James Bond evil lair no it's
definitely it's definitely evil well I
drove in and you know they say they're
like drive in and they're going to have
a parking spot for you now I drive a
huge car like an obnoxious car and so
they go oh you just pull your car right
behind Conan's right there that shiny
blue gorgeous Tesla and there's like 4
in to get by your car mhm and I was like
I can't hit Conan's car I couldn't park
there so I left the facility and I
parked myself in a parking garage on
Larchmont this is so if you're going to
validate this for me I'm going to owe a
lot of money when I leave because of
this parking
situation we have we have a bit of a I'm
going to be honest with you we have a
we're in a wonderful facility beautiful
facility as you attest gorgeous and we
do editing here for this uh tv show I'm
doing for HBO Max and we can do podcasts
here uh we make our own honey and we
make ale here uh we have we run medieval
fairs out of this place so there's a
birthing center there's a birthing
center I wish I would have known yeah
and I'm a doua yeah and um well I mean I
say I am I don't really know what's
going on the worst I'm the worst I'm
like what's happening this is
disgusting vomiting yeah who said
there'd be fluid he doesn't want to look
at the vagina oh no don't even talk
about it when's the stor
coming I was told there was a stor you'd
be the best jul we' be laughing so hard
but uh no we have this great facility
and you can chime in cuz Adam Adam sax
is here and he's one of the uh fellow
masterminds of this whole thing but it
is beautiful but it is there's not a lot
of parking no and um really isn't I mean
sometimes there's no parking for me and
you'd think I would have parking what's
going on now you have a nice comfortable
space don't you I get here
first that's it's an incentive to get
here really early so that I get a spot
and um right if you're Andy rector's
here he's got a spot and so I pulled in
and um first of all I was hoping that
you would hit me because that be great
well you've got that big bang money you
know I mean you're a big success and I
would I would quickly run out and
pretend that I was in the car oh yeah
and be like my neck my neck
quo
quo see I knew that that's why I parked
in a parking structure on large you say
you drive a big car uh is it like two
Hummers strapped together side by side I
actually drive an 18wheeler nice very
nice I got my license for that recently
and I enjoy driving it around town
people love it people love it um no but
I really didn't want to hit your car and
so it's fine I'm not I'm not a is done
I'm not into my possessions I'm not a
very materialistic person said the guy
with the blue Tesla yeah and it's very
shiny and very clean by it looked like
it was like lights were like streaming
down it was like we have it lit you have
it lit yeah yeah what we have it lit
from all different angles there's better
Lighting on my car in the non-p parking
space that I don't have than there is in
this studio right now a lot of things I
love about wintertime M so cold outside
you gather inside with your Chums yeah
your Bros highfive them yeah and you sit
around a crackling fire and you know
what you do what crack open a cold one
that's it isn't it that's it it is it is
it is y and when you crack open a cold
one you better make sure it's Miller
Light ah the best one sit around there's
a roaring fire maybe we've just roasted
some chestnuts probably not no one does
that really no then they crack open a
Miller Light and it makes the
conversation kind of flow everyone's
happy you guys are talking about sports
we are talking about sports we're
talking about hockey we're talking about
highly we're talking about trucks we're
talking about cars we're talking about
things we enjoy and every now and then
we stop we high five and we have some
more Miller Light yeah and then it's got
that clean finish oh don't even get me
start on the clean finish and it's only
96 Cal 3.2 carbage per 12 ounces again I
did those calculations m Great Taste 96
calories go to millerlite.com to find
out delivery options near you you don't
have to go to the store delivery options
or you can pick up some Miller Light
pretty much anywhere they sell beer if
you walk in and they sell beer my guess
is they've got Miller Light celebrate
responsibly Miller Brewing Company
Milwaukee Wisconsin 96 calories and 3.2
carbage per 12 ounces I could not wait
to come back today because I remember
last time I was here I think I spent two
straight hours laughing I don't even
think I talked well you were on you were
on something it was Co I wasn't I wasn't
even there I remember I they I got there
a little late and they said kayle's been
here for an hour and she's in the studio
alone laughing she just laughing so it
wasn't me yeah that's true and you you
know but but uh your life so much has
happened in your life you have uh a
10-month-old today child today today I
had a baby 10 months ago um how's
everything going oh my God Sona how old
are yours they're two and a half oh my
God you had two at the same time did why
did you do that I I honestly I I don't
know it's crazy it is really crazy it's
a lot boys how are and you look so
rested oh do I yes I think it's just a
lot of makeup because I'm I'm not rested
I mean Matt's got a two two and a halfy
old yeah two and three months yeah we
were just talking about not getting any
sleep she's in the Navy now right
she she's actually a seal a Navy SEAL
yeah she's bad
amazing thinking of just I'm thinking of
cuz my kids are are how many months are
your kids my my daughter's
51 my daughter's my son is 49 700 yeah
exactly he still did months months is so
congratulations you're 900 50 months old
um uh I hate hearing myself say 10
months it really annoys me before one it
a li you don't have a choice it's a lot
it's like almost one right the month
conversation it is this is the thing is
I'm I'm pulled back into it all because
I remember viscerally what it was like
when our children were you know 10
months old uh and then you it's funny it
starts to drift away and go away if you
I think this is very very sexist but if
you're the guy I kind of start to forget
and I'll say to my wife isn't it funny
you because she was like I don't forget
any of
it what do you mean you
forget of course you forget you you ran
off and did a talk show every day
you yeah exactly and I'd say oh
I had a kind of a rough time today with
George Clooney yeah
exactly he kept talking about a prank
and I couldn't come get him to come to
the
point and then I had this ve that wasn't
quite to my liking at a restaurant and
then made my way home after a few Cosmos
how's the
baby know it name not
really but uh but anyway so it's yes she
does not forget you will not forget any
of it you know what I hate though and
you can tell me if you hate this too
what I hate is how everyone now is like
hey
Mama what is that I'm just like right I
had a call on the way here and she was
like how's Mom life and I'm like this
the same 10 and a half months ago like I
don't it's the same like I I just I get
like this visceral angry reaction like
hey Mama you're looking so good I'm like
well what did I look like before like
I'm
sobody so you're in a 7-Eleven just
trying to get some slim gems and like
hey M Mama yes it's they know you have a
baby and all of a sudden you're mama yes
and you look good yes but it's like a
difference than just looking normal good
yeah they expect you to look wow you're
alive and
walking you're living
today you're out in the world
no I can't believe it and I'm like your
eyes are still in their
s power of speech Yes it's just
ridiculous you know I had to tell on
this last job that I did because they
were all calling me Mama I actually had
to tell my assistant to tell everyone
and I'm not I'm easy like I'm I'm
whatever we're I'm good I'm good but
everyone was calling me mama so often
and I was really hiding and I was like
I'm not going to like let it let them
call you that don't get mad I started to
really resent everybody and I had my
assistant call a meeting and tell
everyone to stop calling me Mama and
they did yeah of course they did yeah
yeah that's quo you imagine I couldn't
take it anymore I think that's fine yes
I do too yeah uh I think I swear this is
a true story I I can't do you have what
about this this is something I'm curious
about um when you were pregnant did you
ever have men put their hand on your
belly who
without your permission because I saw
that happen once or twice it's weird
right it was me the one that was doing
it yeah I was on the subway I didn't
think they'd catch me no no um no I I
saw I I saw one or two times I saw
someone reach over and put their hand on
my wife's belly but it was people we
kind of we knew them but I always
thought like wow that is a move I would
never I know I am so phobic about the
touching yeah I just do that to
non-pregnant women yeah that's that's
someday there'll be a baby in here
weird what an awful mve that's weird let
me feel where the baby will one day be
one day be oh it's so gross I just that
is the creepiest now I keep thinking
about that and wondering why I didn't
think of it yeah I know hey there let's
just feel where that someday a baby
might live in this
apartment I'm throwing up
God what it's the rubbing it to that
makes it Nursery come
on